i mean to me personally but i think to a
lot of people the human side of things
is very interesting
so testing intelligence for humans what
um
what do you think is a good test of
human intelligence
well that's the question that
psychometrics
is is interested in what is there's an
entire subfield of psychology
that deals with this question so what's
psychometrics the psychometrics
is the sub-field of psychology that that
tries to
measure quantify aspects of the human
mind so in particular community
abilities
intelligence and personality threats as
well
so uh like what are might be a weird
question but what are like the first
principles
of the of psychometrics that is
operates on you know what what are the
priors it brings to the table
so it's a field with a with a fairly
long history
um it's so you know
psychology sometimes gets a bad
reputation
for not having very reproducible uh
results and some
psychometrics there's actually some
fairly solidly or producible results
so the ideal goals of the field is you
know tests should be
be reliable which is a an ocean type
reproducibility
it should be valid uh meaning that it
should actually measure what you says
but you say it measures um so for
instance if you're if you're
saying that you're measuring
intelligence then your test results
should be created with
things that you expect to be correlated
with intelligence like
success in school or success in the
workplace and so on
should be standardized meaning that you
can
administer your tests to many different
people in the same conditions
and it should be free from bias meaning
that for instance
uh if you're if if your test involves uh
the english language
then you have to be aware that uh this
creates a bias
against people who have english as their
second language or people who can't
speak english at all
so of course these these principles for
creating psychometric tests are
very much knight you all i don't think
every psychometric test
is is really either reliable
um valid or are free from bias but at
least
the field is aware of these weaknesses
and is trying to address them
so it's kind of interesting um
ultimately you're only
able to measure like you said previously
the skill
but you're trying to do a bunch of
measures of different skills that
correlate as you mentioned strongly with
some general concept of
cognitive ability yes yes so what's the
g
factor so right there are many different
kinds of
tests tests of intelligence and uh
each of them is interested in in uh
different aspects of intelligence you
know some of them will deal with
language some of them
we deal with a special vision maybe
mental rotations numbers and so on
when you run these very different tests
at scale what you start seeing is that
there are clusters of correlations
among test results so for instance if
you look at uh
homework at school um you will see that
people
who do well at math are also likely
statistically to do well in physics
and what's more uh there are also people
do well at math and physics
are also statistically likely to do well
in things that
sound completely unrelated like writing
in english essay for instance
and so when you see clusters of
correlations
uh in in ethical statistical terms you
would explain them with a latent
variable
and the latent variable that would for
instance explain uh
the relationship between being good at
math and being good at physics would be
cognitive ability right and the g factor
is the the latent variable that explains
uh the fact that
every test of intelligence that you can
come up with
results on that on on this test end up
being correlated so there is some a
single uh a unique variable
uh that that explains this correlations
that's the g factor
so it's a statistical construct it's not
really something you can directly
measure for instance in a person um but
it's
there but it's there it's there it's the
art scale and
that's also one thing i want to mention
about psychometrics
like you know when you talk about
measuring intelligence in in humans for
instance
some people get a little bit worried
they will say you know that sounds
dangerous maybe that's not potentially
discriminatory and so on and
they're not wrong and the thing is so
personally i'm not interested in
psychometrics
as a way to characterize one individual
person like if if i get
your psychometric personality assessment
or your iq i don't think that actually
tells me much
about you as a person i think
psychometrics is
most useful as a
statistical tool so it's most useful at
scale
it's most useful when you start getting
test results for
a large number of people and you start
cross-correlating these test results
because
that gives you information about the
structure
of the human mind in particular about
the structure of human cognitive
abilities so
at scale psychometrics paints
a certain picture of the human mind and
that's interesting
and that's what's relevant to ai the
structure of human currency abilities
yeah it gives you an insight into it i
mean to me i remember when i learned
about g
factor it seemed
it it seemed like it would be impossible
for it even
it to be real even as a statistical
variable like
it felt uh kind of like astrology like
it's like wishful thinking among
psychologists
but uh the more i learned i realized
that there's some
i mean i'm not sure what to make about
human beings the fact that the juke
factor is a thing
that there's a commonality across all of
human species
as there destiny to be a strong
correlation between cognitive abilities
that's kind of fascinating yeah actually
so human connective abilities have
uh a structure like the the most
mainstream theory of the structure of
connective abilities
is called a chc theory it's a kettle
horn carol it's named after
the three psychologists who contributed
key pieces of it
and it describes uh currency abilities
as a hierarchy with three levels and at
the top you have the defector
then you have broad cognitive abilities
for instance through the intelligence
right
that that encompass a
broad set of possible kinds of tasks
that are all
related and then you have narrow
cognitivity is at the last level
which is uh closer to task specific
skill
and there are actually different
theories of the structure of
connectivities that just emerge from
different physical analysis of
iq test results but they all describe
a hierarchy with a kind of g-factor
at the top and you're right that the
g-factor is
it's not quite real in the sense that
it's not
something you can observe and measure
like your height for instance but it's
really in the sense that
you you see it in in ethical analysis of
the data
right one thing i want to mention is
that the fact that there is a g-factor
does not really mean that human
intelligence is
a general in a strong sense does not
mean human intentions can can be applied
to any problem
at all and that someone who has a high
iq is going to be able to solve any
problem at
all that's not quite what it means i
think um
one one popular analogy to understand it
is the sports analogy if you consider
the concept of
physical fitness it's a concept that's
very similar to intelligence because
it's a useful concept it's uh something
you can intuitively
understand some people are fit uh maybe
like you
some people are not as fit maybe like me
um but none of us can fly
absolutely so constrained to especially
even if you're very fit
that doesn't mean you can do uh anything
at all in any environment you you
obviously cannot fly you cannot uh
survive at the bottom of the ocean and
so on
and if you were a scientist say you want
you wanted to precisely
define and measure physical fitness in
humans then you would come up with a
battery
uh of tests uh like you would you know
have running
android meter uh playing soccer playing
table tennis
swimming and so on and uh if you
run these tests over many different
people you will start seeing
correlations and test results for
instance people who are good at soccer
are so good
at sprinting right and
you will explain these correlations with
physical abilities that are
strictly analogous to cognitive
abilities right and then you would start
also observing
correlations between biological uh
uh characteristics like maybe lung
volume is correlated with
being a a fast runner for instance
uh in the same way that there are
neurophysical
uh correlates of cognitive abilities
right
and at the top of the hierarchy
of physical abilities that you would be
able to observe you would have
a g-factor a physical g-factor which
would map to physical fitness right
and as you just said that doesn't mean
that
uh people with a with high physical
fitness can fly doesn't mean
uh human morphology and human physiology
is universal
it's actually super specialized we can
only do the things
um that we were evolved to do
right like we are not appropriate to to
to you you could not exist on on venus
or mars or in the void of space
but on the ocean so that said one thing
that's really striking
and remarkable is that
our morphology generalizes
far beyond the environments that we
evolved for
like in a way you could say we evolved
to run
after prey in the seminar right that's
very much
where our human morphology comes from
and that said
we can we can do a lot of things that
are that are
completely unrelated to that we can
climb mountains we can
we can swim across lakes uh we can play
a table tennis i mean table tennis is
very different from what we were evolved
to do right
so our morphology our bodies or our
sensor motor affordances
are of a degree of generality that is
absolutely remarkable
right and i think cognition is very
similar to that
our cognitive abilities have a degree of
generality that goes far beyond
what the mind was initially supposed to
do which is why we can you know play
music and write novels
and and go to mars and do all kinds of
crazy things
but it's not universal in the same way
that human morphology and our body
uh is not appropriate for actually most
of the universe by volume in the same
way you could say that the human mind is
naturally appropriate for most of
problem space potential problem space
by volume so we have very strong
cognitive
biases actually that mean that there are
certain types of problems that we handle
very well and certain
certain types of problem that we are uh
completely adapted for
so that's really how we interpret
the g-factor it's not a sign of strong
generality
it's it's really just a broader the
broadest cognitive ability
but our abilities whether we are talking
about sensory motor abilities
or cognitive abilities they still they
remain very specialized
in the human condition right
within the constraints of the human
cognition
they're general yes absolutely so but
the constraints as you're saying are
very limited what
i think yeah limiting so we we evolved
our cognition and our body evolved in
very specific environments
because our environment was so viable
fast changing and so unpredictable
part of the constraints that that draw
of our evolution
is generality itself so we were in a way
evolved to
to be able to improvise in all kinds of
physical
or cognitive environments right yeah um
and for this reason it turns out that
uh the the minds and bodies that we
ended up with
uh can be applied to much much broader
scope
than what they were evolved for right
and that's truly remarkable
and that goes that's the degree of
generalization that is far beyond
anything you can see in artificial
systems today right
um that's it it does not mean that that
uh human intelligence is anywhere
universal yes yes it's not general
you